hello and welcome to this video playing
just kit yeah let's see what happens
after 1.e4 was the Scandinavia yeah he's
actually is a student of John before
abusive effort if I never know correctly
i had many kings Indians against her
he's a is a very tricky player I have a
negative score from fantastic positions
quite clearly remember that so what was
not before about what Queen takes d4 oh
my god going I'm falling to kindergarten
trixia he can just take the flow of
course ah ni g3 I wanted to prevent
Bishop f5 which is not a thread really
yet take the fourth come on take it
there is no trick okay i can go Queenie
to wear so maybe maybe there was some
some point to it that wasn't actually
planned
so what's going on here just let's keep
it simple okay Cal seriously take with a
pawn here right okay em so 94 so let's
see you if I can I do something quickly
here like night age 5 or something
9h five castles Knight f6 it looks
pretty dangerous King king age 8 and I
don't see I don't see how I'm winning
this it looks pretty awful Queen g4g 6
let's try yeah we have to try them so
let let's see you can I share something
directly a Quincy for g6 Bishop d3 was
my idea but then probably five or
something wacky comes I can also go
Queen d2 but not quite clear that that
doesn't threaten all that much f4 would
be nice like strategically nice to
prevent any five moves so Queen g46 know
it tends to take it
g6 you for something yeah this is so
strange maybe he has 35 and this kills
me somehow yeah II five may be
threatening Bishop f5 and all my the
tech comes to nothing yeah in that
strange games in a strange game
sometimes looks like look like nice
attack but II 5ss the end of it not in
threatening anything it's pretty pretty
awful or maybe 95 is still possible but
yeah yeah it's got Bishop f5 I have no
move now nothing good I can go 95 and I
was amazing I wonder what I did wrong
there I saw that denied hanks but I mean
retreating is totally useless it doesn't
it take it okay for whatever reason he
could have taken it
check it doesn't do all that much I mean
you over loop the move but King edge aid
and I legit now can play King a gene and
it didn't didn't do all that much maybe
no doesn't help maybe I can do this
actually I mean Bishop takes Queen takes
at the end he has to cover the pawns
them c7 in particular
eight
it works right don't don't tell me
that's a miracle what not yet okay okay
okay language is not coming back from
that one still that was really strange I
mean this is whole thing here with the
Knights so let's just join join this
here Jay I don't know night h5 look like
the thing to do but the any wants to
play just looking one yeah probably this
is better I mean strategically speaking
I'm in really good shape here this
Bishop is not doing anything and the
night is not good and so on I mean also
this looks kind of good if you ask me
just preventing me five it was awesome
tempting to play it couldn't couldn't
really resist but it's probably going
nowhere Queen III is made 23 ah no back
23 oh yeah it's been major basically
made my god yeah that would have been
nice I wondered why the computer did I
mean then then this is good then this is
good actually if if I have to start work
the engine gives rookie aid and
something and then FF for it why doesn't
it give f 49
seven interesting now g45 here quickly
occurring the night very rear position
so I could have I could have got to them
yeah the thing is this is a pure Bluff
you can take the you can take the night
very quickly decided not to do it here i
mean i don't think i have enough here
maybe maybe another engine isn't all
that convinced wants to do this clock
and blackest like it better but this I
kept probably hold if I can tikz need
hmm interesting Jim and now it was a
total mess okay overlooked that one and
here yeah the thing is that here at the
NC 7s weakish at the f7 so we had night
xt4 wow you're that's not holding here
and kind of lucky that it's equal for
some reason which I don't quite get at
the mode okay this the route chinks are
this coming t5 Wow now but now it gets
gets to some advantage hold like it
should be better for black or winning 94
when I didn't see that short but see I
can I can just take stuff okay
all right if I've already was working
but this is a safe a signal and it was
like that for the cool name ok guys
thanks for watching